everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve a pretty interesting problem from
today's leak code contest detect squares
so this is a pretty challenging problem
for a medium but it's actually pretty
easy once you know the trick behind it
so that's what i'll be explaining to you
the trick for detecting squares or even
generic rectangles within a
grid so we're basically designing a data
structure with three
methods three functions we're going to
be given a stream of points and we want
to store these points that we're given
they're going to be two-dimensional they
have an x and y-coordinate you can see
some examples down here and we could
even have duplicate points in the exact
same spot and we do want to store those
so a good data structure to use would be
a list so that's one data structure
we're going to be using a list or an
array list so storing the points is the
easy part but we're also given a second
requirement to implement the count
method and this count method will take
one parameter a point so a single point
that may or may not already be in the
you know stored list of points but it
could be a new point or something and
given that we want to be able to count
how many possible
exact perfect squares are we able to
make with this new input query point and
all the points that we already have
stored within our list so suppose that
this was the query point then we want to
know how many different ways can we make
squares if we are allowed to choose any
of the points that we already had stored
let's say all of these three points were
already stored then clearly we could
make uh one point or one square right
what if we had two duplicates of this
point on the top left then how many
squares would be able to make well
technically we'd be able to make two
squares right we could swap the top left
point if we had two uh you know two
copies of it so then we could make two
what if we had two copies of this point
and we had two copies of the bottom
right point how many squares could we
make then in that case we could make
four squares where i got this for is
basically by multiplying how many copies
we have of this and how many copies we
have of this so that's going to be
important so
uh we're gonna since
you know the count of how many uh each
point that we have matters i'm gonna be
using a map or a hash map to basically
count the number of occurrences for each
point so now for the actual trick the
important part of this problem the most
brute force way is going to be an n
cubed approach why exactly is that well
let's say we're given this a query point
then we want to run through all possible
combinations of the remaining points we
have right we want to do an n
an entire loop uh you know going through
every single point suppose that point
was in the top left position then we
want to do another end loop to suppose
every point was in the bottom left and
an end loop for every bottom right point
and then we want to check okay does this
combination of four points actually form
a perfect square or not so that's really
not efficient right and it's actually
not super easy to code either so what's
an easier way to do it and we do need a
tiny bit of geometry to kind of
understand how we can make it more
efficient so suppose we're given a query
point right what's an easy way to
determine
the rectangle of this point or of you
know trying to make a square what's an
easy way to determine that well since
we're actually dealing with squares it's
a little bit different than the trick
i'm going to show you but i'm going to
show you a trick that can apply to all
that's a little bit more generic and it
could apply to rectangles as well so if
instead of detecting squares we wanted
to detect rectangles i'll show you the
way that we could do that so we're given
a point right this point we want to find
a diagonal point from this one so
instead of doing three n loops like
instead of doing three for loops to find
every single you know matching pair of
three points we're just going to run a
single loop and supposing that every
single point we have available to us was
the diagonal point from the query point
that we're given now we want to verify
if it could actually form a square how
do we know if this diagonal point with
this query point could actually form a
square well of course the height
difference of them or the y difference
of them has to be the exact same as the
width distance or the x distance between
them right
so that's something we can easily verify
by just taking the difference of the
coordinates of these two points right
once we have verified that we know it's
possible if these two points are
diagonal to each other for them to form
a square and once we have that we have
actually
uh you know then we can instantly check
an o of one if it's possible that these
two form an actual square given the
current points that we have how can we
check it with o of one well remember we
do have a hash map right what are we
going to say suppose the coordinates of
this point are p x and p y or you could
say q x q y for the query point and
suppose the coordinates of this bottom
point are x and y we want to know does
there exist a top left point how can we
check that by taking the x coordinate of
this point and the y coordinate of this
point and checking if that exists in our
hash map in other words we could check
this coordinate x and p y how do we
check the bottom right point the exact
opposite right we take p x and
y and check does this exist in our hash
map right since we're using a hash map
that'll be an o of one lookup right so
that's really easy so then we can
instantly check if we can form a square
or not but remember we could maybe have
three copies of this top left and maybe
we could have two copies of the bottom
right so we want to take the counts of
them and then multiply them together and
we can do that easily with our hash map
because with our hashmap we are storing
the counts of each of these points that
we have in our input and remember the o
of n loop is only iterating through the
diagonal list of points okay so now
let's get into the code and i think i
mentioned at the beginning that we are
going to use a list but now that i think
about it the list is actually not
necessary so we can actually even
shorten up the code from what i
originally had so we're just going to
use a map so this map is going to be
called points count it's going to be a
dictionary in python or you know a hash
map and if you use default dict it'll
just make things a little bit easier for
us so if we try to
retrieve a key that hasn't already been
inserted here then the default value of
that will be zero that's what basically
this provides for us and that's just
going to make the code a little bit
shorter for us but so every time we're
given a point right add point all we
want to say is the you know the count of
this point has increased by one right
that's very easy to implement with a
hash map we'll just say uh for this key
uh by the way a list can't be a key
value for a hashmap in python so we're
gonna have to transform this list into a
tuple so this point will be converted
into a tuple and then
we can increment that count by one so if
it doesn't already exist in the map its
default count will be zero and then
we'll add one to it so pretty
straightforward here now for the
interesting part is the count function
so we want to count you know the number
of ways we can create a square initially
we'll say set that result to zero we'll
extract the uh x and y coordinates of
the query point that we're given so
point can be you know we can easily get
the x and y coordinates of it and then
we're gonna iterate through every single
point in the list of points that we've
saved or in our map so every x y in
the points count we don't uh
want the count of this particular point
remember this loop is just going through
all possible diagonal values to the
query point that we're given in the
input right but we need to actually
verify that this is a diagonal point so
how can we do that well we're going to
say
is the absolute value of the difference
between the y-coordinates equal
to the
absolute value of the difference between
the x coordinates if that's true then we
can continue if it's not true meaning
these are not equal then it's not really
possible for these to form a square at
all if they're diagonal to each other so
in that case we're just going to
continue to the next iteration of the
loop but they also mentioned in the
problem description that the squares
have to have a positive error area
basically that means we can't just use a
you know we can't just stack four points
at the exact same coordinate and call
that a square i don't know if
technically that is a square or not but
that square would have zero area so what
we want to just make sure to avoid that
case we just want to say this x can't be
equal to the query point you know or if
the y is equal to the query point then
we're also going to continue right so if
if these points are stacked on top of
each other you know if they're not
really diagonal to each other then we're
going to continue so other than that now
we know that these two points are
diagonal to each other so now we want to
know can we actually create a square
with them or not how can we know if we
can create a square with them well we're
going to say
does the point in our points map so
points count does that
let's say you know one of those points
which is x and p y does that point exist
and does the opposite point
exist as well
both of these points have to exist so
you know just copy and pasting and
updating the coordinates so this will be
the opposite
so as i mentioned the drawing both of
these points have to exist and what
we're going to do is just multiply the
counts together right because if each of
these is one then one times one is one
we can create one point with the one a
perfect square
with these coordinates right if it's 2
and 2 then we're going to multiply 2
times 2. we're going to say there's four
possible ways we can create a perfect
square with these
and we're just going to take this
multiplication and add it to our result
which we declared up above and you know
that's the entire thing obviously you
can tell pretty easily that this is a
linear time function right once we're
done with that we can actually just go
ahead and return the result okay so it
looks like we are just going to
implement this using a list so instead
of iterating through the keys of that
i'm just going to be maintaining a
second variable i'm sure you can do this
without that but i'm tired of trying to
get this to work in python so i'm just
going to go back to the first solution
that i implemented so
yeah we're just going to be maintaining
a list as well as the hashmap so every
time we get a point uh we're going to be
appending that point onto this list of
points that we're maintaining and then
when we want to iterate through all the
points that we have we're not going to
iterate through the map we're going to
iterate through the list of points that
we implemented so self.points
and then we are good to go the solution
will work but one thing i did notice is
i did have a little typo here so the x
and y coordinates uh
it needs to be x first and then y for
some reason i put y and then p x so
let's just swap these around p x y so
these are the two opposite points as we
showed in the drawing picture and we're
just iterating through the list of
points so that being said the code
should work hopefully it does so let's
try submitting it and as you can see
below it does work i hope it's pretty
efficient i hope this was helpful if it
was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot consider
checking out my patreon where you can
further support the channel and
hopefully i'll see you pretty soon i
hope this video taught you something new